في حلب عامر حلبي ما اهم ما سجلته ما
تابعته هذا اليوم في جولتك في هذه الاماكن
عمرو
عبد القادر الصوره كاد مشابهه للايام
الماضيه منذ اليوم الاول للزلزال وحتى
اليوم لكنها بصوره اكبر التداعيات
التداعيات الكارثه
تزداد يوما بعد اخر عمليات النزوح وموجات
النزوح مستمره من البلدات التي ضربها
الزلزال والتي
والتي كان فيها النصيب الاكبر من الدمار
خصوصا نتحدث عن جنديرس في ريف حلب وبلدات
اخرى في ريف ادلب مثل سرمدا الدانه
ترمانين سلقين وابصينا ومناطق اخرى في ريف
ادلب عمليه النزوح هذه المستمره
يقابلها عدم جهوزيه لاستقبال هؤلاء
النازحين بجوار كل مدينه ينزح منها
النازحون الذين دمرت منازلهم او التي
هربوا منها خوفا من الهزات الارتداديه
المستمره ما بين الفينه والاخرى هذه عدم
الجهوزيه ادت الى ان كثير من هذه العائلات
النازحه افترشت العراء نحن خلال جولتنا في
ريف حلب وكذلك في ريف ادلب عاد في الطرقات
الواصله او على الطريق الواصل ما بين
المدن الرئيسيه في شمال غربيه سوريا
شاهدنا مشاهد لم نشاهدها طوال سنوات الحرب
وطوال سنوات
الماضيه هنا في سوريا هنالك عشرات
العائلات حتى الان ورغم ان صورهم منذ
ثلاثه ايام قد ضجت بوسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي وايضا بتقاريرنا التي نتابعها
تتاليا على شاشه الجزيره لكن حتى الان ما
زالوا في العراء تحت اشجار الزيتون على
الارصفه مشاهد مؤلمه مشاهد كارثيه للصوره
الانسانيه المتداعيه التي يعيشها النازحون
هنا في شمال غربي سوريا هنالك مدن لم تعد
صالحه للسكن
لاجل ذلك اقيمت مخيمات ما بين الابنيه
المتداعيه احيانا تشاهد مخيمات بجوار
المدن الاحياء نفسها تش ما بين ما بين
البناء والبناء
خيام عشوائيه يسكنها النازحون الرجال
يسكرون في
يبيتون في السيارات والنساء بتنا في
الخيام مراكز الايواء منتشره وبكثافه
هنالك مساجد صالات افراح صالات عزاء يوجد
فيها نازحوم لكنها لا تتسع هذا من حيث اين
يسكن النازحون اما من حيث احتياجاتهم
ومتطلبات حياتهم فانهم حتى الان لم يصلهم
شيء مما يسد به رمق معيشتهم من الطعام او
من الشراب شكرا لك من اعزاز في حلب مراسله
الجزيره عمرو حلب